[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem mittwoch die vom sport hat
norbert könig mit guten nachrichten aus
belgien schön knapp und das sind einige
unsere themen heute
quarantäne ohne lohnersatz ungeimpfte
die sich nach einem corona kontakt ab
sondern müssen tragen die kosten bald
selbst
spuren im netz nachdem tankstellen maut
von idar oberstein prüfen ermittler die
kontakte des schützen zu corona leugnen
und
jubel bei den deutschen radfahrern das
mixed team landet bei der rad-wm ganz
oben auf dem podest
der druck auf ungeimpfte wächst weiter
wer in quarantäne muss und nicht geimpft
ist bekommt künftig deutschlandweit
keinen ausgleich mehr für entgangenen
lohn darauf haben sich die
gesundheitsminister der länder geeinigt
bisher läuft das so wer in quarantäne
muss weil er kontakt zu infizierten
hatte bekommt in der regel geld vom
staat eine entschädigung für seinen
verdienstausfall
spätestens ab dem ersten november soll
sich das bundesweit ändern wer sich
nicht impfen lässt obwohl er das könnte
geht leer aus es sei denn er erkrankt
selbst dann greift weiter die
lohnfortzahlung im krankheitsfall britta
spiekermann
ein maschinenbauunternehmen in baden
württemberg über 4000 beschäftigte in
diesem bundesland gilt bereits währung
wir impfte wegen cupid 19 in quarantäne
muss der bekommt keine lohnfortzahlung
mehr das gilt nicht bei erkrankung aber
wenn die garantien aus
sicherheitsgründen erfolgt die
unternehmensleitung hält das für einen
problematischen einkauf also wir als
unternehmen glauben daran dass das
impfen hilft die pandemie zu bekämpfen
aber dass die politik jetzt versucht
durch die hintertür unternehmen menschen
zu zwingen sich impfen zu lassen halten
wir nicht für den richtigen weg was in
baden württemberg gilt auch andere
länder sind schon vorgeprescht soll bis
spätestens erster november bundesweit
umgesetzt werden heute einigten sich die
gesundheitsminister von bund und ländern
es geht um die umsetzung nicht kann es
nur noch mal sagen eines bestehenden
gesetzes und wir glauben auch dass wir
da konsequent bleiben müssen es werden
ja auch ab dem 11 10 die kostenlosen
tests in manchen bereichen wegfallen
auch das ist eine konsequenz und ich
kann nur jetzt noch mal alle auffordern
sich wirklich impfen zu lassen für
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn ist
impfen ein gebot der solidarität
diejenigen die sich und andere durch
eine impfung schützen
haben ja dann auch die berechtigte frage
warum eigentlich für jemanden der im
urlaub war ein risikogebiet und weil er
nicht geimpft ist der dann in quarantäne
muss warum sie dann für so jemand mit
zahlen gewerkschaften kritisieren es
bestehe schließlich keine impfpflicht
zudem gibt es erhebliche
datenschutzprobleme sie entstehen neue
konflikte in quarantäne fall muss dann
der arbeitgeber die den nachweis
erhalten warum eine kern zähne
angeordnet wurde und das gibt dann
rückschlüsse auf die gesundheitliche
verfassung der beschäftigten und das ist
genau das was wir nicht wollen ein
weiteres problem sei die gefahr einer
pandemie im verborgenen ich hätte die
entscheidung mir anders gewünscht weil
das hat hier das risiko dass diejenigen
die kontaktpersonen sind aus der
quarantäne bedürftig sind das die sich
gar nicht mehr melden so dass wir die
kontaktpersonen gar nicht mehr alle
erfassen weil sonst die lohnfortzahlung
nicht gezahlt werden könnte heute im
endspurt die kanzler kandidaten und die
kandidatin kein streit in ihren parteien
über die gestrichene lohnfortzahlung
vielmehr weitgehende einigkeit die
impfquote so auf der hebel finanzieller
druck
quarantäne und lohnfortzahlung antworten
auf die wesentlichen fragen und den
neuen regeln im detail finden sie in
unserer zeit erfreute app
schauen wir auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen in deutschland das robert koch
institut meldet zehn
1454 neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden das sind 2001 weniger als
vergangenen dienstag die sieben tage
incidents sinkt erneut und liegt jetzt
bei 65
nach wie vor groß ist die betroffenheit
über das verbrechen an einem 20 jährigen
in einer tankstelle in idar oberstein
ein kunde soll ihn aus wut über die
masken pflicht erschossen haben dafür
gibt es im netz sogar vereinzelt beifall
die sicherheitsbehörden warnen vor einer
zunehmenden radikalisierung von corona
leugnern auch der mutmaßliche täter hat
in den sozialen medien entsprechende
spuren hinterlassen susanne gehen hat
noch stehen die ermittlungen am anfang
es ist eine tat die entsetzen auslöst
unfassbar zynisch und schrecklich nannte
sie die rheinland pfälzische
ministerpräsident in
bereits jetzt dass dieser schreckliche
wort
instrumentalisiert wird
das beobachten wir natürlich ganz genau
denn das internet ist kein rechtsfreier
raum wir sehen dass es eine
protestbewegung gegen die staatlichen
beschränkungen maßnahmen aus dem bereich
der korona luckner und im lager der
sogenannten querdenker gibt der 49
jährige mutmaßliche täter gab an er habe
aus ärger über die aufforderung des
kassierers gehandelt eine maske zu
tragen
er habe ein zeichen setzen wollen
viel spricht dafür dass der mann zur
gruppe der korona verschwörungs
gläubigen gehört das wäre für deutsche
sicherheitsbehörden keine überraschung
es gibt seit längerem im internet
aufrufe widerstand gegen eine angebliche
corona diktatur zu leisten nach
zdf-informationen verbreitete der
mutmaßliche täter bereits 2009 10 auf
twitter verschwörungstheoretiker inhalte
zb meine muskeln sind gespannt mein
geist geschärft gnade denen welche diese
situation heraufbeschworen haben
aufgebaut haben die wir so vorher gar
nicht kannten und mittlerweile hat sich
tatsächlich eine szene herausgebildet
die gut miteinander vernetzt und der
viele menschen folgen der
verfassungsschutz bundesweit ist
alarmiert
es darf nicht sein dass wie bei den
reichs bürgern früher man lange solche
leute einfach nur verniedlichend als
spinner abtut und sie dann aber gewähren
lassen hier muss mit der ganz klaren
kante des rechtsstaates agiert werden um
dem ganzen grenzen zu setzen es gelte
einer gefährlichen entwicklung
rechtzeitig entgegenzuwirken
nach afghanistan nach dem abzug der
bundeswehr wartet der großteil
ehemaliger ortskräfte samt angehörigen
immer noch auf eine chance zur ausreise
möglicherweise sind es deutlich über
10.000 menschen ihre genaue zahl wird
nach regierungsangaben gerade ermittelt
viele sind in kabul gestrandet oft unter
erbärmlichen bedingungen anton
kurschilgen er hat zehn jahre für die
bundeswehr in afghanistan gearbeitet als
die taliban die macht übernahmen floh er
von kundus nach kabul und wollte raus
aus afghanistan
doch es gab keine chance jetzt sitzt er
hier fest in diesem zeltlager in einem
park in kabul genauso wie diese frau mit
ihren sechs kindern
sie war fünf jahre für die deutsche
gesellschaft für internationale
zusammenarbeit tätig auch sibel raus aus
afghanistan
ich habe es am flughafen von kabul in
eine maschine geschafft dann haben sie
meiner ausreise dokumente kontrolliert
und mich aus dem flugzeug geworfen sagt
sie unter tränen
sie haben mehr als 5000 menschen aus
afghanistan raus geholt soldaten und
soldatinnen der bundeswehr über der
evakuierungs mission dabei waren dafür
gab es heute ein dankeschön von der
bundeskanzlerin und der
verteidigungsministerin beim rückkehr
appell im niedersächsischen seedorf
kramp-karrenbauer rechtfertigte 20 jahre
bundeswehreinsatz in afghanistan heute
aber auch an die die noch in afghanistan
sind und die unsere hilfe unsere
diplomatische und politische hilfe
brauchen um das land zu verlassen es ist
natürlich sehr traurig für die leute und
wir konnten jetzt vielleicht nur einen
kleinen teil rausholen wie viele
menschen in afghanistan noch auf ihre
rettung warten ist unklar allein in dem
zeltlager in kabul sind es tausende
die evakuierungen müssen unbedingt
fortgeführt werden und es ist auch
essenziell dass die menschen die
tatsächlich nach europa kommen nach
deutschland kommen hier schutz bekommen
es geht zum beispiel auch darum dass
humanitäre visa schnell verfügbar
gemacht werden und dass die menschen
umfassend schutz erhalten wenn sie in
deutschland sind wie das umgesetzt
werden soll ist aber völlig unklar
eine afghanistan reportage sehen sie
auch im zdf auslandsjournal allein unter
taliban heute um 22.15 uhr
frankreich und die usa wollen ihren
streit entschärfen und wieder einen
dialog beginnen das vereinbarten die
präsidenten beiden und makro in einem
telefonat paris hatte seinen botschafter
aus washington abgezogen aus ärger über
das nicht abgestimmte handeln der usa im
indisch pazifischen raum frankreich
hatte dadurch in australien einen
milliardenschweren im boot auftrag
verloren
zuvor hatte us-präsident beiden bei
einem virtuellen corona gipfel eine
spende von weiteren 500 millionen
impfdosen angekündigt sie stammen von
beyond eckpfeiler und sollen an ärmere
länder geben beiden schwor die staats
und regierungschefs auf ein gemeinsames
ziel ein bis september 2022 sollen 70
prozent der weltbevölkerung gegen das
virus geimpft sein die usa sind
mittlerweile der größte spender von
corona impfstoffen weltweit
schnelle maßnahmen gegen den klimawandel
das fordern führende wissenschaftler auf
dem extremwetterkongress in hamburg
ansonsten drohten nicht umkehrbare
folgen sagen sie und mehr wetter extreme
was das konkret bedeutet hat in
deutschland die flutkatastrophe im
sommer gezeigt und klar gemacht wir
müssen uns vor den klimafolgen schützen
aus hamburgs henry
wer hier flaniert ahnt meist nicht dass
eine der beliebtesten promenaden
hamburgs die stadt retten kann das hier
ist ein gerade erhöhter deich er soll
sturmflut mit bis zu acht meter neunzig
über normalnull zurückhaltend 1 meter 70
mehr für fast 80 millionen euro
die stadt hat auch schon sich auf den
klimawandel ein gestellt und gesagt wir
sehen die schutzmauern höher und nicht
die des hafens tätig steht sozusagen auf
einer künstlichen
und bei sturmflut und das ist ja schon
häufiger passiert
machen wir die schotten dicht wie
dringend solche anpassungen überall in
deutschland sind zeigt ein blick auf die
temperatur entwicklung die tage mit mehr
als 30 grad höchsttemperatur in einem
jahr nehmen immer stärker zu wärmere
luft kann mehr feuchtigkeit aufnehmen
das begünstigt starke regenfälle die
temperaturunterschiede erzeugen starke
winde sprich extremwetter die
infrastruktur muss sich anpassen die
waren etwa sucht mit satelliten nach
bäumen die bei sturm umkippen können das
hamburger geoportal zeigt wohin wasser
bei starkem regen fließt und wo sich
sammelt um soetwas bundesweit anzubieten
müssten viele einzelne behörden ihre
daten bündeln wir arbeiten alle sehr
intensiv zusammen aus unseren
unterschiedlichen fachdisziplinen an der
herausarbeitung der verwundbarkeit der
verkehrsinfrastruktur für wetter und
klima effekte und auch in die ableitung
von von möglichen maßnahmen eine
flutwelle von mehr als zehn metern höhe
wie sie diesen sommer vorkam hätte eine
solche online anwendung wohl auch nicht
vorhersagen können wohl aber wo
gefahrengebiete liegen
nach dem vulkanausbruch auf der kanaren
insel la palma am sonntag schließen die
lavaströme unaufhaltsam weiter richtung
küste die behörden warnen trifft die
lava auf wasser kann es zu explosionen
kommen dann entstehen wolken giftiger
gase die augen und atemwege reizen
tausende sind bereits geflohen mehr als
300 gebäude wurden zerstört
der ausbruch und dessen nachwirkungen
könnten laut experten noch bis zu drei
monate anhalten
nach berlin dort gab es heute einen
festakt mit selbstkritischen tönen wir
deutsche hätten beim thema kolonialzeit
blinde flecken sagte bundespräsident
steinmeier zur wiedereröffnung zwei
museen
im juli schon war im berliner schloss
der erste teil des humboldt-forums
eröffnet worden jetzt sind darin auch
die ethnologische sammlung und das
asiatische museum zugänglich besucher
erwarten mehr als 10.000 exponate aus
der ganzen welt einige sind als
koloniale raubkunst umstritten stefan
nase bürger
vor dem berliner schloss proteste gegen
das humboldt-forum gegen raubkunst und
forderungen nach rückgabe
drinnen gibt es spektakuläre räume zu
bestaunen hof kunst aus china etwa oder
höhlenmalereien aus buddhistischen
tempeln einer der höhepunkte ist das
luft boot aus dem heutigen papua
neuguinea die sammlungen sind in der
zeit des kolonialismus entstanden und
hoch umstritten denn die objekte wurden
gekauft und getauscht aber auch geraubt
erbeutet und erpresst anlässlich der
eröffnung mahnte der bundespräsident
heute sich mit dem deutschen
kolonialismus auseinanderzusetzen
das unrecht das deutsche in der
kolonialzeit begangen haben geht uns
als gesellschaft als ganze etwas denn in
unserem land gibt es auch in der
gegenwart mitten im alltag dieser
gesellschaft rassismus diskriminierung
herabsetzung von vermeintlich fremden
die nigerianische schriftstellerin team
am andern gucci beantwortete die oft
gestellte frage danach wo afrikas
schätze hingehören mit dieser gegen
frage
wohin gehören die schätze deutschlands
diese frage ist überflüssig denn
natürlich gehören sie nach deutschland
als ehemalige kolonialmacht sitzt
deutschland auch schätzen aus aller welt
einiges wird bleiben können anderes aber
wird wohl zurückgegeben werden müssen
sechs deutsche sind heute rat
weltmeisterin geworden und für einen von
ihnen ist das ein ganz besonderer tag ja
für ihn gilt wenn es am schönsten ist
soll man gehen und was ganz schöner sein
für den 36-jährigen wahlschweizer tony
martin als mit seinem achten
weltmeistertitel dem ersten im mixed
sextett von der großen radsport bühne
abzutreten bei der wm in flandern mit
recht gebührt ihm der platz an der sonne
ein bilderbuch abschied für tony martin
mit goldmedaille und im wm trikot
zufrieden darf er bereits nach getaner
arbeit sein er der motor im dreierteam
mit max wahlscheid und nikias arndt
zweitbeste zeit nach der männer hälfte
hinter italien eine medaille möglich nun
waren die frauen dran in diesem erst
zwei jahre alten nichts zu wettbewerben
lisa brennauer dieser klein und mieke
kröger auf flachen kurs um brügge
stärker als die italienerinnen in der
zwischenzeit bereits in führung doch es
droht gefahr von den niederlanden mit
weltmeisterin van dyk und
olympiasiegerin van vleuten die zwei
besten werden gestoppt brennauer und
klein klare bestzeit vor italien die
kollegen dürfen sich schon über silber
freuen und hoffen auf gold und
tatsächlich die beiden top fahrerinnen
der niederlande kommen nur unwesentlich
näher der rest ist pure freude
es war heute einfach eine ehre hier
nochmal für toni auch hier den sieg
einfahren zu können und so wie immer
aufhören wenn es am schönsten ist und
ich hätte mir keinen schöneren tag wenn
man abschied vorstellen können schnell
noch die passende kluft übergestreift
und dann nur noch feiern und genießen in
den einzelwettbewerben waren wenige
andere noch etwas schneller als
mannschaft aber waren sie die stärksten
die grizzlys wolfsburg finalist der
vergangenen saison haben mit einem 1 0
gegen die schwenninger wild wings
zumindest vorübergehend die
tabellenspitze übernommen chris des user
nutzt einen krassen abwehrfehler der
schwenninger zum entscheidenden treffer
koberg verliert vor dem tor die scheibe
und das war's heute kann sich allerdings
münchen die tabellenführung zurück
und das war's und wir haben noch eine
premiere jetzt filme aus dem weltall
gibt es hier reichlich aber noch keiner
wurde tatsächlich dort gedreht bis jetzt
die russin julia parisot soll nun der
erste wirklich schwere lose filmstar
werden die 36 jährige schauspielerin und
ihre crew haben drei monate lang
trainiert in einigen tagen soll es
losgehen zum filmdreh auf der
raumstation iss über den film ist wenig
bekannt nur der titel herausforderung
aber hollywood wohl nachziehen mit tom
cruise auch auf der iss da ist was los
im weltraum jetzt noch lotto
gewinnzahlen lauten 35 13 21 22 31 und
die superzahl 7 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 5 157
zum herbstbeginn heute kommt morgen der
erste herbststurm mehr dazu hat gleich
aus denn terry claus kleber begrüßt sie
viertel vor zehn im heute-journal und
hier übernimmt morgen christian sievers
danke für ihr interesse alles gute ihnen
und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ja passend zum
herbstbeginn heute erreichte uns morgen
ein herbststurm der erste der saison
quasi und dieses tiefe das bringt regen
und auch viel wind vor allem an der
ostsee das ist ein sturmböen dabei aber
auch an der nordsee wird es finde ich
auch dort sturmböen drin im süden
deutschlands herrscht eher hoher
luftdruck schauen wir in die nacht da
wird es im norden allmählich verdichtung
geben also die wolken werden dichter und
der wind schlägt zu ansonsten ganz im
süden aufgeklart in gewässernähe bildet
sich nebel und im süden deutschlands
wird es kalt temperaturen gehen zurück
bis auf drei grad örtlich kann es sogar
bodenfrost geben 14 grad gibt es
richtung nordsee morgen also im
tagesverlauf dem durchzug des sturmtiefs
mit regen und viel wind sturmböen an den
küsten im süden merkt man kaum was davon
es gibt viel sonnenschein temperaturen
im südwesten bis 23 grad an der ostsee
16 grad und die nächsten tage werden
immer wärmer am freitag bis 23 grad im
norden viele wolken am samstag dann bis
24 sonntag bis 26 aber dank ziehen
gewitter auf ein schöner abend